I believe that this conversation should
have great importance to women who have
men in their lives that they care about
and I'll tell you
why um not just for the hey let's see if
we can get inside their head because
everybody's different but but uh men
obviously uh you've built a great
following but I see a lot of and I
dismiss criticism uh of Y oh this guy
hates women and he's just teaching men
to be Predators I I don't believe that
I've read the videos um I I've watched
the videos uh I have I which I now
believe is a second version of your book
um which you have an amended version of
of the book which uh is the one I have
but here's my point there's so many
women in my audience uh who are OB often
looking to
me not because I'm uh better than what
they have I'm sure they've traded up but
which is fairly low bar I I deal
outwardly with struggle I I think that
we don't talk about struggle we don't
talk about suffering because it's
embarrassing it's belittling it's
shameful it's self-indulgent it's
selfish and we're afraid of it of
exposing our weakness and yet it's such
a universal and there are tools and
tactics many of which you discuss uh in
your work that we could be sharing with
one another so what I think is
interesting is while you're coaching men
to improve their their prospects let's
say there's also a fundamental
understanding in there for women of the
insecurities that men have you know once
my wife said to me much smarter than I
am you don't need all the muscle you
don't need to be strong and I said yeah
you're right I said here's my problem
okay you think my problem is maintaining
my problem is as a 50 plus year old man
is that I went through a phase of not
knowing why I was here anymore outside
of the intellectualism of the work and I
believe in I believe that journalism is
an act of faith in the future and of
course it's flawed it's flawed like
everything else that's Human by Design
but I believe in it but
personally you know I try to provide
what I can I'm a parent I'm a friend
these are very important things to me
but I'm not who I
was I would get my am much more a SE
seasoned
tactical um self-defense person I don't
believe in fighting I only practice
self-defense because I don't believe in
rules once we get that line crossed
other than the law but I lost that sense
of yeah I I don't need these muscles
because I'll never be strong like I was
I'll never be dangerous uh like I was
without a weapon I'll never be athletic
like I was anymore those days are over
my son is 17 I outweigh him by 75 pounds
and he is all I can handle on a regular
basis just because of his you know his
Youth and his vitality and just how
strong his his muscle connections are um
and women don't get that they don't get
very often not to generalize but I think
a lot of men don't let the women in
their lives
know what they need and that they
need and I wonder what you think about
that I'm sorry to overe explain it but
it's how I process and what role that
could play in better relationship
ship yeah so you know the bookmark that
I placed in my head when you were
rambling presenting that I'm not going
to call it ramly let's call it a a
speech is you know it open with Chris
why do you need all that muscle you know
is what the M said it's like you know
you think to yourself yeah do I really
need all the muscle you know I thought
to myself a few years ago because I've
always I mean I've always trained I've
always been a big guy because I was
always interested in looking strong and
um you know when I ENT to the run you
know there's a reputation about yourself
that sort of precedes you when you have
that that that physical presence and I
thought to myself you know what would
happen if I had to get into a fight
because I've never been into a fight you
know like how do you handle that so I
got into boxing because I wanted to
challenge myself and you know again I'm
a kid of the 70s so I'm not a young man
um I had a boxing competition earlier
this year with a gentleman who was 20
years younger than me two inches taller
and about 35 pounds heavier and let me
tell you that that creates a lot of fear
in you when you face off against another
man you put your jaw on the line and and
you have to hit him and you have to hit
him harder than he hits you because you
want to win it's a lot of work so I mean
back to the original point of like you
know Chris what do you need all that
muscle for like you don't need it sort
of thing I always find that interesting
because what what women say and what
they do meaning like what their
behaviors are I always believe the
behaviors and she's chosen you Chris I
mean you're obviously married you've got
children together you have a family if
you were inadequate and she liked 5
foot6 110 pound she'd probably leave the
marriage and move on to that but she
hasn't so there's something to be said
about the physicality and you know the
strength that you impose um as a man and
the masculinity you sort of bring to the
table like that's a lot of testosterone
right women like that so I think one of
the one of the narratives one of the
struggles one of the stories that that
that men need to get their heads around
is watch watch women's behaviors watch
watch the behavior in general of people
I'm not just narrowing this down to
women but again you know I talk a lot
about dating but watch the behavior of
people and don't listen to so much of
what they say their actions Express
their priorities right I mean like one
of the big complaints that guys have you
know when it comes to the Realms of
dating is like you know I was a friend
and I was her shoulder to cry on and
then she went off and you know with Mr
exciting and you know Mr exciting is
always like you know 6'2 broad shoulders
narrow waist football player linebacker
sort of thing and the guy with the chess
master's degree he's just not getting
you know responded to women like a
strong virtuous tall masculine man they
want to look up to a giant they want to
know that you got it and being
physically strong is part of that
equation you'll never get out of that
you'll never get out of that so how do
you justify that how do you reconcile it
Richard with this with what we see all
the time now especially with social
media and everybody flaunting
exaggerated ideas of their life the 5610
guy who runs a hedge fund and has
nothing but the most beautiful women
even if they're you know um somehow
being compensated for their presence and
guys seeing that and saying so if I
don't if I don't have the
bank and that's what this culture
rewards more than anything else whether
you're from Canada or America or from um
you know Sri Lanka if you don't have the
cash
that's the real currency pun intended in
our society and that's your only measure
of worth it doesn't matter that you can
keep me safe doesn't M matter that
you're powerful my black card will beat
you it's a measure of worth but it is
not the entire measure of worth though
because I mean the thing being is is now
you're talking about the the the
multifaceted pieces of puzzles that are
required to complete The Narrative of
hypergamy and all that really means is
that women generally date are cross and
up on the socioeconomic scale they want
to be with a guy that's better than them
and that's fine it's not a problem with
women it's a reality and it's a feature
of the the survival nature of human
beings had women chosen losers
throughout history you and I would
probably not be sitting here today
incompetent men that couldn't get food
or protect the tribe would have you know
we would have just gone the way of the
dodo so women choose winners right so
that's fine and being uh like a 5 foot6
very successful Banker uh brings
Financial Resources to the table and
again that's one piece of the puzzle but
it's not the entire piece of the puzzle
right like women have a long long
laundry list of uh requirements that
they tend to have in men when I got um
separated a number of years ago I was at
this dinner party and you know I was
with this group of entrepreneurs and the
wives were there and the girlfriends and
stuff and I was single all the time and
one of my friends you know wife came up
to me she goes You Know Rich I got to
set you up with Becky you know you got
the six sixes and I got to connect you
and D I'm like well what are the six
sixes I've never heard of this before
right and she said well you know you're
six fo tall six figure income 600 power
car 6 months out of a relationship 6
inches in the pants I got all these like
sixes right I'm like okay well that's a
long list of uh requirements that you
have to introduce me to your friend I
don't even know what she looks like but
it's like you know it's it's not you
know he's got a nice job and he's a nice
guy right it's not you know he's a
pleasant fellow that uh you know makes
his bed in the morning right it's it's a
reality of the world right like there
there are areas that we need to compete
in as men and being competent
financially being able to and money is
what makes the world world go around
right I mean it's on the money you know
In God We Trust money all this sort of
like it's it is our religion you know in
general if you don't have money you're
not going to have women around on a
long-term basis you might have them
around on a short-term basis I mean I've
seen lots of stories with guys telling
me that they lost their wife for their
girlfriend to the guy that just got out
of jail with a neck tattoo and the
teardrop tattooed under his eye doesn't
have a pot to piss in or a window to
throw it out of but he looks like a
badass and she'll throw you herself at a
guy like that for a couple of nights but
she'll go back to the guy with the money
so it's like there's all these moving
pieces and I think understanding that
it's not just you know just be jacked or
just be rich or just be captivating or
just be compelling or just have a good
social network and influence these are a
lot of the pieces of the puzzle but
they're just pieces of the puzzle I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out